[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
happy
happy hump
[Music]
day a lot of stuff going on today
out there in the politics
tomorrow we have a big day tomorrow
huge day tomorrow you've seen the uh the
thumbnail for our show today you've seen
our title for today jared and ivanka
ditched trump apparently we're going to
hear some of the recorded testimony that
they gave the january 6
select committee tomorrow during the 90
minute presentation it appears that the
presentation tomorrow is going to be 90
minutes i'm sure there's going to be
more of a hearing
a little bit more on the front and the
back you know that we are going to
broadcast live
from the midas touch youtube channel
that is right we are going to bring you
coverage
at 7 00 p.m eastern
i'm going to be hosting the midas touch
january 6 select hearing special
coverage i will be hosting over on the
midas touch youtube channel so make sure
you go follow over there the link is
over there um we will put the link
uh in the chat today we will also
also what we're going to do
is we are going to be spreading that
link around for everyone to
link to retweet put on facebook
so that way you guys can listen to the
hearing um i again i will be hosting the
coverage the special coverage of the
january 6 select committee
the hearings tomorrow on midas touch
youtube channel we will be on an hour
before the hearing the hearings gavel
down at 8 00 pm
eastern time
so that's 9 00 p.m
central time
but we will be starting our coverage at
7 00 eastern so an hour before we will
also have coverage after the event
the presentation that is given and this
morning we find out that it's possible
that ivanka and jared have ditched trump
and they're going to publicly
show that in their testimony some of the
recordings that they made
of the of their testimony in the hearing
so they will show that
to the world
so we'll see we'll see exactly what
happens exactly what they said exactly
what they testified to
and if they told the truth i guess i
would imagine i would imagine that jared
and ivanka you know
announced this morning
that they might be moving to miami it
seems like they're getting closer to
cuba does it seem like that to you like
they're getting trying to get as close
to cuba as they possibly can does that
seems sus i don't know
i don't know i'm not sure if that's
suspicious or not i mean it seems like
it could be
they're getting closer and closer to
cuba as their testimony gets closer and
closer
to be revealed to the world
oh jared and ivanka jared and ivanka
jared and ivanka
they're the real hunter bidens left up
it was like oh hunter riding he's
profiting off china or ukraine or
someone in russia
i don't know
all the while
jared ivanka took gazillions of dollars
in foreign money particularly from the
saudis
while and
not only that in chinese chinese
copyrights
basically they protected ivanka trump's
brands in china which they don't
normally do in china
but they gave her
actual trademarks in china
china china china china it's always
projection with these [ __ ] isn't it
it's always
always projection with these [ __ ]
the trump family the trump crime family
benefits financially from trump being
the president of the united states
the entire family
the the entire f and it wasn't just the
[ __ ] ones that worked in the white
house it was the ones that seemed for
him on fox news and newsmax constantly
and i'm talking about beavis and
butthead dumb and dumber
eric and don jr he's [ __ ] crackheads
they constantly benefited from him being
president financially
and like hunter bad lacks hookers and
cocaine yeah yeah he likes hookers and
cocaine
a lot of degenerates like hookers and
cocaine like don jr he's a [ __ ]
degenerate
who likes hookers and cocaine
i i'm just going off the evidence here
folks
just going off the evidence not making
any real claims that no one knows look
at the guy he's even with the jack jaw
and his and his and his girlfriend gavin
gavin newsome's ex-wife come on
come on man
don't doubt me
but we're gonna hear from jared and
ivanka tomorrow and that is important
it's important
because they were standing there
apparently uh white house counsel uh
silly siglione is um
also in talks to
appear in the hearings i'm not sure if
it's the daytime hearings or this
thursday hearing i doubt thursday
because it's a presentation but maybe
the daytime hearings or the other prime
time hearing you you know that this
deputy
chief counsel
a deputy counsel to the white house was
in the room with donald trump on january
6th
so he is a witness
to donald trump's
attitude his intention
or lack
thereof i i have a feeling that this guy
has ill intent not intent
the cheeto dust mobster for the cheeto
dust kangaroo it is super important
tomorrow the coverage
and we got a lot of stuff going on
there's a hearing going on right now
that is um
it's it's it's sad uh we've been talking
about gun violence
in this country we've been talking about
it on this show for for several weeks
now since since well for years
really now
we've been yelling and screaming about
it since the shooting in buffalo when
the the maga king mass shooter white
supremacist went into a grocery store to
murder black people
and then we had
the second amendment enthusiast down in
uvalde texas he was able to obtain two
semi-automatic
ar-15 style rifles with 1700 rounds with
no money he bought him with a credit
card the minute he turned 18
so that he could go murder
dozens of little children
which he did yesterday we watched a
video that was very hard to watch a
teacher from uvalde who was shot twice
and all 11
every single one of his children that
were in his classroom 11 of them
murdered not just murdered but torn
apart by these weapons
that steve scalise says oh well after 9
11. we didn't we didn't ban airplanes
you are a dumb [ __ ] steve
scalise
i i would imagine that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] is going to end up on bonehead of
the week you
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me we didn't
ban airplanes
we didn't ban airplanes in this country
after 9 11. you are a dumb [ __ ]
number one airplanes are not
manufactured to murder people number one
number two you dumb [ __ ]
we did a hell of a lot of [ __ ]
airplane regulation a [ __ ] hell of a
lot of it jesus christ you remember one
guy decided to try to hide a bomb in his
shoe and we [ __ ] banned shoes
you had to take off you have to take off
your [ __ ] shoes still i think i
haven't been on a plane in a while but i
think you still have to take off your
[ __ ] shoes
you stupid [ __ ]
steve scalise you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
everyone wants to oh well he was shot he
was shot he who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]
then the [ __ ] should know
something about gun violence
nope
can't help it can't help but bathe in
that nra money
even after he's a victim of gun violence
he's like you know
an old getting shot thing that was bad
but uh and i almost died hell i could
barely walk for a while but you know
what you know what
that nra cash boy it flows
it flows like the waterfalls
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him
whip why the [ __ ] is he in leadership
got in front of a microphone today and
said after 9 11 we didn't ban airplanes
we didn't regulate airplanes or air
travel at all you are a dumb son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] steve scalise
they're terrified of what matthew
mcconaughey said yesterday in the white
house terrified they're like oh these
[ __ ] hollywood elites
who are from holly he's from you he was
born in uvalde
born in uvalde
when he heard about it he lives in texas
you [ __ ] idiots he drove to umaldi
to talk to the families because he's
from there
matthew mcconaughey was not born and
raised and bred in hollywood
he said he's he's he's a texan
matthew mcconaughey goes to the white
house yesterday
gives a speech and then you know there's
some of the stuff in the speech i
haven't watched the entirety of it
i've been uh a little occupied with the
hearings but i tried to catch parts of
him we're gonna watch parts of it today
now parts of it that are very heartfelt
um that matthew mcconaughey went and
talked to some of the families there in
his own in his hometown
and tried to agree with them and he
tried to express that grief
in front of the press at the white house
yesterday and let me tell you the right
wing is absolutely [ __ ] going bonkers
going [ __ ] bonkers remember when they
were they were excited about matthew
mcconaughey
now they're not now they're not because
he's like ah you gotta have some [ __ ]
brains
right
when he's bashing the left because he's
quote-unquote a centrist
you know that that's his own
self-declaration that matthew
mcconaughey is an aggressive centrist
when he's bashing the left they [ __ ] and
love him
but boy and and he's a texan he's a real
true texan when he's attacking the left
but when he when he says anything about
common sense gun safety
or talks about guns at all in a way that
would
make make people with gun boners get
really scared get really scared that
they might not be able to have gun
boners anymore
he's all of a sudden some kind of george
soros blood sucking cabal hollywood
elite
like just in a moment in an instant
isn't that funny how it works these
[ __ ] right-wingers have lost their
minds
lost their goddamn minds their ever
loving minds
and matthew mcconaughey is some kind of
left-wing hack the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] he is not
he's not a left-wing hack
but he gave a
speech yesterday in the white house
again part of it that we're going to
watch and again you cannot look away
from this
because he talked about gun reform and i
i believe that matthew mcconaughey is
sincere
in his
extending an olive branch
to folks who
own guns
who want common sense gun reform who
want gun safety who would be willing
would be willing to give up their gun
if it meant
that it would save other people's lives
maybe a particular gun that they have
i i i i do believe that there's a
handful of people out there that would
say you know what i would voluntarily
do a buy back for some of these guns if
it meant
that little bitty children in a school
somewhere weren't slaughtered and
decapitated by one of these rifles by
one of these
these weapons of war that are not
designed to be in schools are not
designed to be on the streets of america
that's not what they're designed to be
but matthew mcconaughey made a good case
yesterday and there's one part where
he's talking about
one of the young children who was
slaughtered
and their parents
and it's it's very tragic it's very
heartbreaking but we will not look away
here
we're not going to look away here you
have to remember this you have to stay
fast on this we have to keep the
pressure up because your children's
lives depend on it
everyone in america's children's lives
depend on it
it's absolutely crucial that we do not
give up on this front
just like we should not give up on the
front of making sure that women had the
right to their bodily autonomy we can't
forget about that these fascists are
coming for it folks jesus we see the
supreme court this morning
absolutely stripping the rights
away from american people to hold
federal agents accountable
all almost overturning bevins vivins
where a citizen has the right to sue
federal agents if they overstep the
fourth amendment
they want a fascist state folks this is
what they want
they want it and they're they're
exploring down in [ __ ] florida
the florida nazi party is exploring and
oh my god the the uh
the desantis simp christina pasha or
however you say everything i don't know
what the [ __ ] her name is who gives a
[ __ ] she's a russian agent as far as i'm
concerned
i mean she's a foreign agent now
she had to register as a foreign agent
it's on brand for the florida nazi party
and that's what they are the florida
nazi party
anyone who follows and is a supporter or
or
a voter for ron desantis in florida
he said oh disney bad mickey mouse bad
dare groomers
so he sent his groomers up to disney to
project with their nazi swastika flags
literally
ron desantis support in florida is a
bunch of let's go brandon nazis real
nazis skinhead [ __ ] nazis
i'm not making this [ __ ] up
i'm just not like oh yeah they're nazis
everyone's like tony you just like to
call people nazis what are you talking
about i'm not calling i'm not calling
anyone who's not [ __ ] waving the nazi
flag around nazis
ron de santa supporters are [ __ ]
nazis
i i mean i could go to the proof but why
why would i have to show you the perfume
folks no
but this is what they want they want a
fascist state they want to take your
rights away especially if you're a woman
especially if you're not a white man who
looks like me they want to take your
rights away
they want to take your vote away
they want to take your ability to be
safe in a grocery store
in a community center in a church your
children in schools they want to take
away their [ __ ] right to learn math
they don't want public education folks
public education
you know makes people know
facts
it helps people with critical thinking
you know critical thinking is really
tough when you're trying to [ __ ]
dilute people with a bunch of [ __ ]
nonsense
like ron desantis donald trump
steve scalise gaslighting us
that oh every night eleven they
been airplanes
they didn't ban airplanes
bone-headed type [ __ ] bone-headed tight
[ __ ] well i mean it shouldn't be
surprising
from the moglodites
you know and it's shrinking it's getting
smaller and smaller i believe that now i
believe that's going to show in the
midterms that there's a lot more people
out there that are against trump
that are against trumpism that are
against this maga [ __ ] regardless if
he's their orange mussolini jesus or not
or if it's some [ __ ] florida nazi
like ron desantis is the head of their
party
we must stand against it everywhere in
every form in every fashion that they
try
to press fascism on us everywhere
and that's what the select community
hearings are going to be about
i know it doesn't feel like it but they
try to steal your democracy
they tried to negate your vote
they don't want you to decide
it's very
very
very important
that we stand against these
fascist
who are coming for your bodily autonomy
they're coming to marry your children in
tennessee
they're trying to strike down your right
to sue federal agents if they overstep
your your [ __ ] rights it is really
funny that the second amendment people
they stop there they don't know the
third fourth fifth amendment i mean
until you get in front of a you know a
federal court and you're trying to cover
up that you overturn the election and
you're trying to [ __ ] steal away our
democracy then the fifth amendment
you know comes into play
but they don't remember any other
amendments after that
but here we are
one day before the hearings one day and
i think this 90 minute presentation is
gonna be a banger
i have a former producer
a tv st a tv producer going to produce
this 90 minute thing i'm sure it's going
to be
something to watch folks and you're
definitely going to watch it so make
sure to go over
make sure to go over to
the minus touch
youtube channel
and subscribe and find that link
and set a reminder for that link again
tomorrow at 7 00 pm eastern we will
start our coverage i'm hosting the midas
touch
coverage special coverage of the january
6 select committee hearing tomorrow
so make sure you go watch that
make sure you follow us there follow us
on on our channel also on youtube
the tonymichaelspod
just go to youtube and search the tony
michaels podcast you don't want to miss
anything
we we broadcast every single weekday
every single one all five monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific right here on youtube twitter
twitch and we simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page if you're over there
on facebook thank you for joining us the
link to our youtube is right there at
the top of the post come over and
subscribe to our channel also follow us
on twitter you're not going to want to
miss the bonehead of the week poll we're
going to do it this week just like we do
every week for all the new listeners out
there we put out a poll on youtube
more reason to subscribe there
and
twitter
for bonehead of the week you decide who
the bonehead of the week is friday in
the second hour of our episode
me and gabe sanchez my co-host and
executive producer we break down the
bonehead of the week your vote you vote
you decide we break it down for you
every single friday in the bonehead of
the week
so don't forget to check that out um i
know this people are talking about the
breaking news and i'm going to get to
the breaking news
about brett kavanaugh apparently and
midas robin has it here uh if i bring it
up here an armed man who made threats
against supreme court justice brett
kavanaugh was arrested outside the
justice home the court says yes that
that is breaking news uh that happened
about a couple hours ago
um they didn't actually arrest him near
his home
or at his home it was it was several
blocks away from what i understand he
wasn't
um
making threats right outside the home
but i'm not sure what the what the rest
of the story is here um obviously
there's tension in this country
especially
towards some of these
some of these decisions that the supreme
court is making look if you want to fix
the supreme court if that's your goal
don't get a [ __ ] gun that's no
[ __ ] salt you're not going to solve
any goddamn problem in this country with
a [ __ ] gun
and that's the problem that we have in
this white privileged gun culture [ __ ]
is everything can be fixed with a gun no
there are no problems fixed with a gun
none
stop that nonsense
the only way to fix our problems in this
country is to use your [ __ ] vote use
your ballot use your voice
in one way former fashion if you're
pro-democracy use your goddamn voice
what do i mean by that tony what do you
mean what do you mean by use your voice
there's all kinds of ways you can use
your voice you can go help a candidate
get elected you can you can ask and talk
to your neighbors and your friends
the people at your children's school the
people at your church at your community
center [ __ ] at the grocery store the
person that checks you out i know you
know cynthia at the grocery store ask
her talk to her
talk to him about pro-democracy
institution pro-democracy ideas i know
they're for it
they just don't know what it is
sometimes and it's going to be super
important over the next three weeks
about these hearings
to be talking to people about democracy
and what it means
it's going to be super super important
we can't forget our pro-democracy
institutions
and we can't forget how important it is
to show people what democracy actually
is
some people want to to have
authoritarianism even even when they say
they're pro-democracy
well let me tell you something merrick
garland just locking up people just
because it feels good that's autocracy
we do not want merrick garland to be a
bill barr
we don't
we want the doj to do its work
and to use the constitution and the laws
in place
to make sure that people are held
accountable whatever that means and it
looks like it's moving in that direction
folks
we see the oath keepers several of them
have
uh took plea deals for seditious
conspiracy we still have stewart rhodes
awaiting trial and then we have uh five
of the proud boys including enrique
tario who met with stuart rhodes
now being
superseding
superseding charges to seditious
conspiracy themselves
if you don't see this moving towards the
president you're not paying attention
there's one person one person who is
tied to the oath keepers and stewart
rhodes and i think these hearings are
going to show this they're going to show
this
roger stone well we call him stodger
brown here on the show
i don't want to make accusations that i
don't know about anyone
i know exactly what he did
everyone you can tell we just need the
proof
it's not [ __ ] rocket science
stodger roane was supposed to get
protection from the proud boys on the
day of the january 6th he actually
received protection before january 6
from the proud boys
and then on january 6
they switched his detail it's kind of
funny how they switched his detail to
the oath keepers seeing that the oath
keepers
had control of the qrf the qrf is the
stash of weapons
that was put across the potomac
so that way when
[ __ ] went awry at the capitol and
martial law was declared they had a
stash of weapons
the magulodytes stove keepers the proud
boys
and roger stone's detail
changed
to the oath keepers jesus christ we have
brian allrich one of
one of stewart rhodes lieutenants
who had direct contact with stewart
rhodes in open court
told the judge
the judge asked
mr aldrich
did you and mr stewart rhodes plan
to obstruct
the peaceful transfer of power yes yes
we did an open court not in so many
words but that was the gist of it
that yes they were trying to stop
donald trump from not
being president
they wanted him to remain dictator
they were going to overthrow our
constitution overthrow our vote now
think about this folks because this is
very important to tomorrow's hearings
even
very very very important and i'm gonna
talk about this
over and over and over the next three or
four weeks with these hearings
is they weren't just trying to [ __ ] on
our constitution
think about think about this for a
second if our constitution was ripped up
and thrown in the trash or flushed down
the toilet or if he would have ate it i
don't know what the [ __ ]
i don't think that paper would be very
scrumptious but again maybe like me and
gabe surmised yesterday maybe he orders
fried chicken flavored paper i don't
know
but here's the thing
if he totally got rid of our
constitution then they would have done
what they wanted to do which is declare
martial law and take your vote and flush
the constitution down the goddamn toilet
you think there would be state
constitutions you think the states would
[ __ ] survive
if the constitution didn't exist anymore
why would the state constitutions exist
if our federal constitution didn't exist
we are the united states of america
i think people are completely
underestimating
that if the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
was or can be successful
underex estimates what their way of life
will look like
your community is gone
your church your school
your businesses you think they're not
just gonna do away with these things
what is to protect
what police force will you have
what fire force will you have if there's
fires
what will you have what safety will you
have
the constitution is more than a document
folks
it's our foundation to our way of life
in this country
to our freedom our rights and most
importantly our liberty
it's in it's in the [ __ ] intro the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not liberty
and donald trump and his lackeys and the
[ __ ] snowflakes that the moglodites
are because they were sad he didn't win
and they don't want him to be prosecuted
for crimes that he has committed he
wanted to be protected by the presidency
that is why
but he wanted to take away your
right to vote your freedom of your vote
he wanted to strip you of your liberty
whether you like it or not
whether you whether you love him or not
he wanted to take away your voice
and your liberty in this country by
stripping you of the vote
and that's what the january 6 select
committee hearings should show
that yes yes and we need again we need
to spread these around
like herpes i keep saying that people
laugh gabe laughs at me when i say this
listen
we have to make sure
that we do the same thing we did with
the debt per trial this is way way more
important than the depth or trial like
this is way more important honestly if
you want to make sure we have more depth
heard trial [ __ ] in the future you
better get off your ass and you better
start spreading around
the facts about the january 6
insurrection that they were trying to
overthrow our constitution they were
trying to take your liberty away you
better start spreading it around
and you better start spreading around
right now today
and tomorrow we'll have clips tomorrow
evening we will start to have clips of
what really happened the facts that you
can put in front of people it is super
important
that we do everything we can to get this
in front of many eyeballs and as many
americans listen to the facts and what
happened in this country and how they
tried to take our vote and our country
away from us it is super super important
and tomorrow you can actually watch the
hearings live with us
on the midas touch youtube channel i
will be hosting
the coverage of the january 6 select
committee tomorrow starting at 7 pm
eastern
on the midas touch youtube channel so go
over there find that link we will post
that link down in the chat we will also
be spreading that thing around like
herpes as well so help us do that and
every single hearing we will be
broadcasting from the midas touch
youtube channel
for their special coverage
so go follow those links stick with us
we'll be back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive
under this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
sticking around through the break
tomorrow's gonna be a busy day
[Music]
we're gonna have the show in the morning
and then the coverage at night the
special coverage on the mighty touch
youtube channel gabe sanchez
how was how was the election in l.a
yesterday you went and voted i seen your
picture i did
i did i did i've i voted uh
how'd that election go let's hear about
democracy here yeah let's see i actually
was just looking up the results uh
specifically for the primary for uh
sheriff villanueva and if people don't
know who alex villanueva is he is the
sheriff of the la
uh
sheriff's department he's the one i mean
there are more gangs in the la sheriff's
department than there are actual gangs
in l.a it sounds like sounds like uh
sounds like there's a problem in the uh
sheriff's department yeah it's almost
like
law enforcement
is the problem
[Laughter]
uh but
you know ellie's had a i had a long
history of law enforcement being part of
problems in l.a
um there's there's a couple really good
documentaries out there on it but what
what what are you seeing as far as the
results are
how did democracy fare out there yeah so
the big ones uh
gavin newsom
um
you know obviously his elections in in
november but his results uh was 56.3
percent of the vote uh attorney general
was bob banta 54.5
we've got the u.s senate which is
padilla
he was at 54.3 percent um
you know well there's actually two right
because he's the interim
uh
us senator that took over for harris
right she became vp and then there's the
other one which was that's who gavin
newsom appointed exactly the governor in
california and in most states when a
senator uh when a seat comes vacant that
current governor um actually appoints a
senator we've seen that federal case
with rod begovic where he
may or may not have tried to sell barack
obama's seat but yeah you know good old
rod rodriguez uh you know
i'm i'm from chicago and uh that one
stung real hard only because it was
right before that our previous
um
governor had also gotten in trouble
for um illegal crimes right so you know
they're i'm not saying all of chicago is
crooked okay we're not all corrupt
but there was a bit of a pattern that
was uh developing here here's here's the
thing here's the thing with rod bugovich
because um the trump trumpers they hold
the oh he's democrat and blah blah and
he's a trump supporter like
when does that tell you about rod rigoy
that's number one number two uh trump
got begovic out of a colorado prison so
yeah he's probably going to support the
guy who got him out of prison i mean
yeah i mean when he got home you know
obviously rod had gone from
he was dying his hair all black so when
he came out of prison he was like just
yeah because there's no there's no hair
dye right right yeah
i mean maybe you could make some hair
dye in a toilet or something like that
but it might be a little bit like shoe
polish or some [ __ ] yeah
so uh or yeah i mean maybe he's using
the same thing as rudy giuliani who
knows but now he's gone all natural he's
done the the silver look um
and i think the thing that kind of
pissed me off the most was after what it
was like maybe within a month or a
couple months or something like that uh
there was whispers of him having his
own podcast show it's it was called
lightning rod i don't know if it still
exists
gotcha uh let's see really quick can i
look it up yep lightning rod with rod
blagojevich
will feature analysis about politics
government trending stories and global
issues
so you know of course the people who are
in trouble and who are uh
felons
uh
get rewarded at the end of the day but
in other aspects of the elections that
were happening especially those that
happened locally here in la we have rick
caruso the billionaire real estate mogul
who was republican turned democrat
um who wants to
his policies are meh uh he wants to you
know obviously fund more of the um
the police he doesn't really have a
solution for
the homelessness in in la and no no real
plan to expand kind of resources
uh but he's going against karen bass in
november so the the split between them
was 42-37 so they'll be heading off
together against each other in november
the la county sheriff is villanueva
versus robert luna it was a 34-25
breakdown
those are the ones that are really
important down here uh a lot of people
seem to like want uh
bass now she was considered for a lot of
different seats one of them was the she
he was she was kind of on the list for
um
biden's pick for vice president at one
point
she was kind of on that short list um
and it seemed like it seemed like she
was going to um you know take advantage
of that but she really didn't campaign
on that she really didn't take advantage
of that right because i think la is more
important to her than just that she was
on the short list right um for being
vice president and and i think that'll
shine through i think democracy is good
i've seen a lot of people uh posting
i believe it was anybody what's that
what's the one candidate's name caruso
it was anybody but caruso that's right
right anybody
yeah i mean i know bass was like most
people who posted that bass was their
you know their choice but anyone but
that that person yeah there's a
let me see if i can find it really quick
i think a nick offerman actually posted
one too i follow nick i think so i seen
one that he did and several others but
uh yeah there's
going around
there is a meme which i will send a link
for right now that basically was kind of
the joke that's being set around here in
la for those who actually care i mean
then again you did have kim k kim
kardashian who was like
if
you're already out voting like not go
vote right not you should go vote it was
i mean like guys look if you're bringing
errands and you happen to be out and if
you're going to start pass a poll if you
know the starbucks yeah
whatever it is yeah and uh you just
happen to say you know what i've got
like
15 minutes to go uh cast my ballot
go vote for caruso which again one rich
person to another rich person uh but
this meme right here
is uh obviously a is a is taken from um
uh
oh man why am i blanking on the name of
this movie hey what don't vote for
hickorys
yeah so it's the scene where um in
hold on what am i why am i blanking on
the snake
you do this all the time you know i
bring it up
he's gay brain
there's too many things in my head i am
simultaneously thinking about other
sketches that i need to film before
tomorrow he's getting all kinds of trip
i have planned
by the way tomorrow gabe is going to be
on the podcast as normal but then what
you're going to see is you're going to
see gabe during the hearings you're
going to see him
in an undisclosed location he doesn't
even know where he's going i don't even
know where i'm going right i'm going to
be in a bunker you're right at the
capitol right it's always exactly this
it's going to be you should do a green
screen and get you yeah i should bring
that with you take it
the movie i'm thinking of
is um
a star is born which is around okay but
this is a common meme that's used where
he goes hey and she's like what and goes
you know just want to take another look
at you but in this one it's hey
what
don't vote for rick caruso she's like
okay
okay
well i i mean i
again that the point is is that you
participated in democracy yesterday a
lot of people in la to participated in
tomorrow i mean if they were out running
errands apparently right if they just
happened to be out about and they were
like
i'm going to take a quick stop from
trader joe's okay
so i have some um breaking news do you
you know um
blake masters have you heard of this gay
yeah he's the one that wants to ban
content
such as
right
he's the one that
donald trump has endorsed yes especially
donald trump jr of course he has um ron
has a video here 73 year old man showed
up at a republican event in a blm shirt
black lives matter
and is physically attacked and assaulted
by you guessed it arizona u.s senate
candidate blake masters
wow this is on film holy [ __ ]
yeah here we go um everyone wants to
watch this video let's let's watch here
as blake masters assaults a 73-year-old
man because he has you know
this cancer culture [ __ ] these cancer
culture nazis are like ow you can't tell
me what to do i get to do whatever i
want but if you show up at a blake
masters event in a black lives matter
you might you just might be canceled so
much so the blake masters himself will
try to cancel you all over your face
let's watch jesus
[Applause]
hey
oh oh
[Music]
okay
you can't hit
you know what i'm a retired policeman
you're a conductor
so it's very uh unclear here so he he
hit a woman
what's going on here i i don't know also
is he a retired law enforcement i don't
know uh let's let's oh she hit him watch
launch
yep she see that man there okay so she
initiated a woman with the phone here
yeah yeah assaulted him probably because
you're wearing a black lives matter he
and he put his hand away to get her in
and she hit him again it looks like okay
um so she blocked there's theirs
so he didn't even so he didn't hit her
he blocked with his hand right it looks
like she well she hit him and he tried
right she hit her blocked and then blake
masters is this blake masters is that
yeah that's blake masters that is blake
masters the masturbator yeah he came in
well
gabe
he's secretly a masturbator it's not a
it's not a thing that we yeah we can't
you know
it has to be overt in this party in this
nazi party look
it's like we always say you know if the
condom fits right well right
i think i bet it doesn't fit blake
masters but probably not that's probably
why he wants to ban him he's like oh
they're too big for me he's like
one small enough i tried to get uh i
tried to get trojan make me custom and
they just laughed me off the phone blake
master size condoms um it looks like to
me and i can't tell
um i don't know who it looks like
holding the the phone here
and that's what it appears is the the
man being assaulted here because there
it appears where blake masters hands are
around his neck you see that yep yep it
appears that way in this video because
there's the arm there's blake masters it
appears
that he is choking him out or throwing
him to the ground i'm not sure which
it looks like he had yeah he was choking
now he's here um
he looks like he's on the ground there
picking up his phone and then it kind of
goes black again they're knocking his
phone out of his hand right and then
somehow they they throw him out of the
and he might have been near the door
anyways
and he's being thrown out and pushed
down by other people being assaulted by
other people right um so he was
assaulted blocked the woman lake masters
came in well with his
tight
hairy grip
and then uh
and then they they brought him down and
they kicked him out blake masters is k
he's a really he's a scumbag but he's
really creepy have you ever seen the
videos that he does of himself like they
know they spend money they spend money
to produce these political videos and
he's like i'm a nazi and i love guns and
my kids love guns and we're going to pew
pew bang bang pew pew pew pew bang bang
but it just it really appears it really
appears to like man you could have had
more takes you could have looked less
creepy surely there was someone
directing on site that could have said
hey man do it less creepy on this one
less creepy yeah but is this we're gonna
like take it from the top yeah the blake
masters comment he comes in like a
goddamn superhero tony he does there he
is right here behind me he sees the
interaction because this woman here with
the phone is the one that appears
who appears to hit and she's mad because
he has the phone because listen what she
says here
[Applause]
is totally legal to have what the funny
part is they are holding they're holding
their phones right i know i know she's
like take you know it's like the person
you know i mean
no offense to that karen's out there who
are actually good people but you've got
the care karen the you know the crazy
white lady entitled privileged person
who comes up and says you know do you
have a permit for this where's your
manager i want to speak to the manager
i'm not going to let you close down the
shop until the cops show up to see how
you have not treated me so fairly you
know right like that like we saw we saw
a ton of them during the pandemic who
thought that their health was more
important than anyone else's
of course of course why would they not
right and this is just another example
of one of them let's finish watching
this one more time because i have some
more breaking news i i hate the game oh
my gosh today is full of breaking news i
know
[Music]
well here's the thing i guarantee those
people came in after and they're like oh
this [ __ ] guy hit her blm oh that's
assault domestic violence guarantee
somebody already made those connections
and that guy especially who's like i got
my tommy bahama shirt on and this guy
hit this woman
well i mean it is he he is wearing a
tommy tommy bahama t-shirt and he is a
former police officer i believe that's
that's the one that said he was a former
police officer look they're going to
cheat and they're going to commit voter
fraud and then later on when he goes
back to his retirement home he's going
to smoke a [ __ ] stogie in his tommy
bahama shirt singing [ __ ] you know
hamburgers in paradise
laura packard this is the breaking news
everyone um
ooh breaking live news
lauren bobert is under investigation for
a fraud i can't wait
tonight is this the one that i tweeted
about a while ago yeah yeah yeah is this
it this is the one let me find the tweet
let's just
hold on i thought this was i thought
this was breaking news no no no no no no
no it is i just called it early early on
oh oh you're saying you're saying you're
saying you're saying you looked into
your crystal ball yeah and i said
because everyone knows we have a crystal
ball here at the tony michaels podcast
we actually what happens is is me and
gabe ship it back and forth yeah like
when elon said he was gonna buy twitter
i had the crystal ball so i looked into
it and it told me that no elon would
never own twitter so i predicted that
from the very beginning and then i had
to ship it to gabe because it took him i
don't know three four or five days to
really come to his senses right that he
would not buy it and i shipped him the
cursor ball he looked into the crystal
ball elon musk but apparently you had
the crystal ball that we send back and
forth when the lauren bober thing
dropped is that right that that is
correct uh let me just look this up
what kind of is it the um is it some of
the
uh it says state attorney general has
referred uh for review a fraud complaint
from the group that targeted oh this is
um
this is a fire bobert i talked about
them the other day have you seen this
group it's the same group that um
is trying that took down madison cother
and it's the it's the video that we got
the cousin touching and the cousin
humping video that we kind of made fun
of
that that's this it's the same folks
that are trying to um
[Laughter]
apparently they've undercovered fraud
and they have uh referred a review
uh from a complaint of a group um and i
believe it's fire bobert i believe yeah
i think that's what they're called yeah
i believe so so it looks like the lauren
bobert saga the [ __ ] around
uh has reached the part of the the first
phase of the find out phase of the [ __ ]
around right saga um where lauren
bourbon and i'm not sure if it's if it's
actually some of the campaign money
because wasn't she using campaign money
wasn't that what your video was about so
yeah there's all your tweet was about
yeah so it basically is is
calling out how lauren bobert was using
her campaign finances to pay rent and to
pay other debts that she had
which is obviously illegal
um but she was also
uh
very very much inflating the amount of
mileage that she i think was like double
the amount that was like this is not
even feasible how you could drive this
much in this amount of time
um and also attempt to claim this much
so people are like these numbers don't
add up
and there were some initial reports
early on and i was like yo you should
we got a few few signs of uh what looks
to be fraud here
um as i you can keep going but i'm going
to keep looking for this okay again i
have too many lauren bober tweets and
too many people tweet about me
about lauren
oh
you don't have a special thing with
lauren bober do you is this um
you know there's no there's no like
bowling alley action or anything is
there no no oh okay okay i just i just
stuff it i'll hold do you think that's
some of the [ __ ] that's gonna drop on
her is is is
footage from the bowling alley i'm sure
somebody has something that they're
gonna drop and they're gonna say there
was a picture i was there when this
happened and then you're gonna see it
and it's like wait that was a dick
that's pretty small right
that looks like a mushroom so the uh and
then what the stormy daniels said about
the the former gang yes
so the other day i seen a picture of
lauren bobert and it appeared that she
was uh hugging what appeared to be like
two male strippers right they almost had
their [ __ ] out yeah i almost had them
it was one of those things i was like i
don't know if i should retweet this one
right right well i mean i i honestly
um it's in perfect style and fashion for
her i mean this is she is probably
i don't know it's it's hard to tell
who's the dumbest congress person who's
the trashiest congress person right
and and who and who is the prop probably
the most are the excuse me the least
qualified congressperson but in a venn
diagram
of all that lauren bobert seems to show
up
in those categories right trashiest
dumbest yeah she is least qualified she
hits all the she hits all the marks all
all
all the all the stuff okay let's see the
this is uh damn it
let's let me get this right let me get
this right i don't want to mess this up
this was one of the tweets that i found
from july of 2021
okay so this is july of 2021 folks see
the seated time stamp there from gabe
sanchez um
gabe says now you're you're doing a skit
here kind of thing yeah yeah um lauren
bobert this is a this is her quote
we don't want government benefits and we
don't want government welfare also
lauren bobert i grew up collecting
welfare which is
that's right that's a direct quote from
her these these are these are not your
words these are her words that you're
that you're typing here
also also lauren bobert so there's a
caveat on the caveat here my business
own
owed nearly 20 000 in state tax liens
because i wouldn't pay unemployment
insurance premiums she said that out
loud yeah yeah well i mean i think it's
this is a uh
uh i have a a version of what she said
now keep going this is well that quote
that i give right there is based on
basically the action she took right so
you're saying the story that i'm about
so then you go down and then there's an
also also also laurent bobert which is
investigated for improper using campaign
funds for my personal benefit
notice she's wearing a mask here that's
kind of funny i like that picture of her
wearing a mask covers up her face um
lauren bobert subtracts seven thousand
miles from campaign
so this is i think this is one of the
first places that reported on the
discrepancy and i was like okay this is
clearly campaign finance and then this
article is the one that's actually
talking about her trying to get away
from paying unemployment claims and this
isn't some kind of liberal
rag like new york times this is colorado
news line right yeah so this is in her
home state and and this is about the the
20 000 in state tax liens right between
august 2016 and february 2020 shooters
grill
the gun themed rifle restaurant
rifle being the town that it's in yeah
yeah the town is called rifle um owned
by bobert
um
eight liens for not payment for
unemployment insurance premiums now this
is very anyone out there who owns a
business know that this is this is a
very common
um
easy thing to do for employers
because it's all self-reported just like
gabe said like miles and stuff with the
irs it's all self-reported right you
don't like the government isn't looking
at every single number that you report
that that's the other fallacy right
about this right-wing government's
watching you and the irs is bad type
thing
and not to say that the irs doesn't make
mistakes or we shouldn't make sure we
have
oversight of the irs but here's the
thing
your taxes are all self-reported it's
all self-claimed
it is it is the honor system in this
country
for your taxes and reporting your taxes
but it's reporting your taxes and then
and then and then somebody going through
and saying wait these numbers don't add
up well or here's the thing yeah when
you become a public official
in some capacity most public officials
release their uh what are those things
called tax returns because what what
that does is it reassures the public
that you're not a [ __ ] criminal in
other words you're not a [ __ ] liar
and you're not a you're not a fraudster
that's why it was so tough to get the
tax returns and we still don't the
public still does not have the former
guy the cheater does mobsters tax
returns and the reason why is because of
this very thing because once people get
them and they go through the scrutiny
they'll find the fraud and he knows
they're fraudulent because he's
self-reporting them folks right there's
no one forcing donald trump to write
down what number in this number and that
number it's all self-reported
on your tax returns but the other thing
too is remember that you know if it were
not for the lobbying from tax companies
like h r block and turbo tax and things
like that we would have a very automated
efficient way of doing taxes which was
they would send you a document that says
hey can you verify
because we know can you verify that
these numbers are accurate well see in
most instances they would know but see
that's that's the thing is what's
happening at the shooter grill thing if
that's the case the 20 000 tax liens
what's happening there is normally an
employer
a
a good steward of business would report
those tax numbers accurately to the
state
and to the federal government and then
they know that about their employees
but if you commit fraud on the business
side of it they the government doesn't
know
what the correct amount is for the
business
the federal and the state government
also they do not know the correct
numbers for those employees because you
have not reported them so that's why
it's so crucial that's why there's
actual there's actual penalties um
i mean there may be a chance that you
know maybe she's not criminally
prosecuted for these tax liens but her
business won't be able to operate
because that's the thing gabe is
everyone you know during the band they
were like oh my right to own a business
and it's not no it's no it's not right
it's not your right there's no
constitutional right for you to own a
business for you to run a business
that's not a [ __ ] thing
the state
the state grants you the right to run a
business you [ __ ] [ __ ] they issue
you a license you have to abide by their
laws in their state
this is really boneheaded type stuff
that
that people out there in the country
believe that they can do whatever they
want whenever they want how are they one
that's not the case
you just don't have the freedom to strip
away other people's rights
and you
you owning a business and not reporting
to the state the correct amount of money
that's supposed to be paid based on the
laws that are in place
that everyone who has elected officials
and they they they develop policy around
those officials that we elect
have decided
you are you are usurping the right of
the people that's what you're doing and
you're really [ __ ] your employees too
yeah because when when you do this
here's the thing her employ her
employees if they report these wrong
numbers on their tax returns now their
tax returns are wrong and it's probably
wrong because they are not paying enough
taxes so she's gonna [ __ ] her employees
by not reporting these numbers and then
their employees are going to end up
owing more taxes
i mean that just
sounds pretty on brand with republicans
let me let me let me uh benefit me not
the type of persona or mentality where
you say
uh
i don't care about you and if you get
[ __ ] over i don't [ __ ] care now but
it's what's it what's important to learn
about this situation is that she misused
funds she inflated her travel
and was corrected and then they said oh
it was just a mistake we accidentally
uh claimed 37 000 miles but it was more
like 30 000 miles i don't know if that
was later adjusted again because this is
from again this is from february of
2021. and and again these tax
authorities sometimes have some leniency
on you amending right you could be like
oh oops i did this whatever i mean like
she undervalued stuff she overvalued
inflated stuff sometimes there is
clerical errors like like right yeah
these aren't
but these are not smart spherical errors
right these are there is clear grayers
and then there's and then there's fraud
which is intentional right uh clerical
errors just because you you mark it
wrong in your tax return or someone
marching wrong or you get an amount
wrong or you find out later maybe there
was more or less of an amount
because of a discrepancy that's not
intentional but you still owe taxes
right
the point is is that if you're
intentionally doing these things you're
you're committing fraud um speaking of
frauds we have some more breaking news
can you imagine that today is just one
we have this uh story and we mentioned
it earlier everyone was talking about
about brett kavanaugh he's he's trending
at number one here on the tweet tweets
have you read this story about an armed
man being arrested near i saw a tweet
about an iron man that
potentially yeah was involved with brett
kavanaugh right i mean clearly brett
kavanaugh's life was not at risk okay
let's just be well because they keep
saying near but this is uh from what i
understand arrested in the street this
is this is the well this is the media is
sensationalizing this a bit he was not
uh very close near his kind of a yeah
but it's also near his home so again i
guarantee he was like in the street or
down the street but we don't know who
this man is we're not really sure yet um
who he is and we're not sure what the
motivation is now again i tell everyone
out there look this is not the way to
push back on the supreme court right
right peacefully protesting writing on
sidewalks with chalk and being loud that
is a way to protest getting a gun is
doesn't solve any problem yeah that's
the problem it seems like there's a
problem again the gun the gun's the
problem
how would you avoid the situation if if
you had an armed gunman how do you
unarm a gunman
by not allowing them to get a gun
adam parkamenko yeah he says a dude with
a gun was arrested near brett
kavanaugh's house today so today is the
day when republicans show us they care
way more about their supreme court pet
than 11 year old in texas this is true
they're going to be yelling and
screaming oh my god i can't believe we
let we let this person get so close
so close to brett kavanaugh's house he
was like three blocks away when he had a
gun
and blah blah blah there was 19 children
slaughtered because greg abbott doesn't
want to it doesn't want to check to make
sure people who shouldn't have guns
don't have guns yep
100 it's greg abbott's fault he bragged
about it he's like hey now everyone in
texas can have a gun no matter who it is
no matter how [ __ ] crazy you are even
if you just committed a felony with a
gun you can get a gun do you think do
you think the back door was open
well i'm i'm sure there's a back door
problem at brett kavanaugh's house i
don't know if it has to do with his
actual back door or
you know what i mean yeah right you know
what i mean yeah i mean i just look at
that i just feel like at this point
i think it's time to harden homes
you know right well you could you could
say that brett kavanaugh's home
sometimes is hardened i'm sure
i'm sure and there is probably a
backdoor issue at brett kavanaugh's home
um you know i'm just i'm just saying
there so we'll we'll follow that news
and see who this who this crazy person
is who got a gun and i'm sure gabe i'm
sure what we'll find out is this person
who has this gun probably got it legally
and probably got it in the state who's
like pew pew pew pew we can't have any
gun regulations
because as everyone knows in dc it's
it's not it's it's not that easy to
carry a gun um speaking of other um
stupid gun things and republicans having
stupid id on guns have you seen this
[ __ ] video of steve scalise
you know i i commented on this video and
i said uh
i guarantee by lunchtime
some republican will say something even
dumber because holy [ __ ] this statement
has to be one of the dumbest things i've
heard just today
but i guarantee someone's going to say
something even dumber could be lauren
bobert could be marjory taylor green i
have no idea
well
this is a really [ __ ] dumb and i
think my response was this dumb
[ __ ] yeah i mean it just it yeah
what else are you supposed to do like
literally he's trying to tell people
that
after 9 11 we did nothing we actually
did the opposite we made sure anyone and
everyone could get on a plane you dumb
so this is the same this is the same
thing that lauren bobert was trying to
push to talk about how after 9 11 we
didn't ban planes the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i've ever heard we you know
obviously involved tsa which has been
proven to be 95
ineffective from preventing any sort of
uh you know uh
crime to be committed which doesn't
really happen so right well let's
let's listen to dumb [ __ ] here
tell us how we should ban airplanes i'm
not sure what he's saying here but let's
listen problems that were creating those
attacks
and airplanes were used that day
as the weapon to kill thousands of
people and to inflict terror on our
country there wasn't a conversation
about banning airplanes there was a
conversation about connecting the dots
how can we try to figure out
if there are signs we can see to stop
the next attack from happening
he just ran right through it it's
[ __ ] idiot man
you [ __ ] boo
can you go back like maybe five seconds
and just repeat what he said there
which one right
is it maybe right there is it right here
after his eye flinches a little bit okay
as the weapon to kill thousands of
people and to inflict terror on our
country
okay first off because i don't think
that's the part you're looking for right
now i'm looking right after but i want
to say something when he says this
he's saying that an airplane is used as
a weapon right which
it was yeah people were able to get on
the plane they were able to fly this
plane into airspace which it was not
allowed
and they were able to fly it in into
several buildings two in new york one in
washington
and kill thousands of people
with these airplanes now
here's the difference
then um this airplane and again the one
difference is at a gun manufacturer when
they're developing these guns they're
not like oh man does this how how how
will this gun operate in the air will it
be a good
you know machine to operate near how
many passengers can this gun hold right
no they're like how many people can it
kill in the least amount of time like
that's what they're talking about when
they're [ __ ] developing these weapons
when boeing
is making an airplane they're not
talking about how many people it can
kill in the quickest most efficient part
of time
this is really [ __ ] boneheaded number
one the weapon that they used was not
manufactured
to kill someone
right
really [ __ ] boneheaded type stuff so
let's listen to this second part there
wasn't a conversation about banning
airplanes there was a conversation about
connecting the dots how can we try to
figure out
if there are signs that we didn't see to
stop the next attack from
happening oh my god
he can't
he literally well and here's the thing
you know the reason why they have steve
scalise go out and say this right is
because he's a victim of gun violence he
was shot he was almost killed he almost
bled to death um and without without the
good guys with guns on the scene that
day he may have bled to death the funny
part is is the thing that saved his life
wasn't the other gun shooting it was
actually them rendering him first aid
yeah so number one number two that's the
reason why they have him out here saying
this
because he's a victim of gun violence so
they're using this gun violence right
the inn because i'm sure if you look it
up
steve scalise is swimming in nra money i
know that probably no
we'll pay you to shut the [ __ ] up about
hey man and we'll pay you to go out and
[ __ ] give your sad story about
airplanes in 911. it's really it really
is [ __ ] gross that here we are 22
almost almost 22 years 21 years after 9
11. yeah and his shooting that he was
shot in 2017. so this is you know five
years june 14th is when he got shot so
he's coming up on a five-year
anniversary
and has the the [ __ ] goal to say hey
guys we need to stop we need to look and
see how the dots are connected to
prevent future events from happening
well i mean gabe at where steve scalise
was shot that back door had a real
problem
i mean the back door to the to the
baseball field that he was shot at
because if you remember he was shot on a
baseball field yeah
what was happening is what congress was
playing
um a a baseball game
congress was playing a baseball game
that day
and they had to you know
they i think the real problem is they
didn't have big-ass gates and
that's probably right they probably
didn't have lots it was just an open
field tony and open field allowing any
person with the gun to come in and fight
what we need to do is harden our
baseball fields is what it is
we need to make every every kind of
community softball baseball field
park
right this any open space sidewalks
we need to put up walls right we need to
put up
uh back doors lockable we
you're going in
for to go up to bat and you're going out
that's right right now running in and
running out that's it no no only one
door in and out of the park and on the
side what this is really stupid [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
[ __ ] now uh speaking of people
speaking in washington about gun
violence did you see the matthew
mcconaughey clip or have you seen this
clip
some of them are hard to watch and i'm
gonna play one that's hard to watch
intentionally because we should not look
away um this is very important that we
see
exactly um
[Music]
what we see but first off i want to show
you how the right wing responded to
matthew mcconaughey's speech at the
white house this is jesse waters on fox
news
with the thumb karl rove um listen
listen
i mean jason miller looks like a thumb
but karl rove looks like his uncle thumb
his uncle phone
wait a second i mean it's very it's very
you got to be bald you need i got a ball
i got to put i've got a bald cap in the
uh in the the costume closet there but i
feel like also the other person that's
very similar to that is who else has
like that
definitely it's not
oh yeah they all they all look like
thumbs why do these republicans look
like they do what they do
i'm here and i'm going to let people
kill kill them children you know like
that's why i mean hey you know
they got to have profits for these guns
man what else are we going to have but
profits for these guns right here's
jesse waters and karl rove um surmising
about who the white house is gonna have
next joking about the actor i'm just
saying you know what are they white
house gonna do now they're gonna put tom
cruise out to talk inflation is this
where we're going that sounds really
ridiculous doesn't the game oh my god
who would actually have tom cruise on
talking about inflation i mean it would
be really ridiculous if jesse oh wait a
second if jessie potter had not
tj
dj paulie d
this [ __ ] who just said the
white house is going to have
is going to have tom cruise talking
about inflation had
someone who knows mo way more about
inflation than john cruz
i mean you know what he does he does
know because it's gtl baby jim tan
laundry cabs here
oh my god you you're a you're a jersey
for sure no no no i only know that i
only know those things because i once
went to a new year's party back when i
uh when it had first come out and they
said we're doing a drinking game and i
said okay
and it was
uh it's all due it's all going to be
themed to jersey shore any time they say
these
handful of words oh so you had to watch
and then yeah so i had to watch these
episodes you were wasted it was ed hardy
it was clubs it was gtl it was uh
it was cabs are here it was wasted uh
yeah it was uh you know snooki it was
any you know it was just random [ __ ]
yeah so i ended up getting wasted you
know what that we should
people could play a drinking game with
our show
they could do like get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] like because i say
that a lot cheeto dust mobster they
could do that one cheated us kangaroo
and people you could make a game out of
that that's not bad it's not a bad idea
here is matthew mcconaughey and to get
back to seriousness here for a second
this is this is literally what jesse
this is the [ __ ] speech that jesse
waters is talking about
right jessie waters is denigrating
not just matthew mcconaughey because
matthew mcconaughey is there to tell the
story of one of the children who had
their [ __ ] face blown off
by this gun that jesse waters definitely
wants the second amendment gun nuts to
have and to use in schools to murder
children right
this is the speech that he's clowning
him for
okay
got it jesse waters on fox because no
one that's watching fox news is actually
going to go watch the speech from
matthew mcconaughey and what he said
we're going to watch it here because i
think it's super important the [ __ ] that
he says and i think it's super impactful
i think if people [ __ ] listen to what
matthew mcconaughey because matthew
mcconaughey is from uvalde he's not some
[ __ ] hollywood elite injecting
himself into a conversation that he
isn't a part of [ __ ] he lives in
texas he's from texas he was born in
uvalde he knows people in uvalde it's
his hometown listen to him talk
about uvalde
[Music]
uvalde texas is where i was born
i swear my
my mom taught kindergarten less than a
mile from robb elementary
the valley is where i learned to master
a
daisy
bb gun
i took that took two years before i
graduated to a 410 shotgun
uvalde is where i was taught to revere
the power and the capability of the tool
that we call a gun
uvalde is where i learned responsible
gun ownership
now you've already called me on may 24th
when i learned the news of this
devastating tragedy i had been out of
cellular range working in the studio all
day when i emerged and messages about a
mass shooting in the town i was born in
began flooding my inbox
in a bit of shock i drove home hugged my
children a bit
tighter and longer than the night before
and then the reality of what had
happened that day in the town i was born
and set in
so the next morning camilla myself the
kids would load up the truck and reach
over your valley
when we arrived a few hours
later gotta tell you even from the
inside of our vehicle
you could you could feel the shock
in the town
you could feel the pain
the denial the disillusion anger
sadness loss of lives
dreams halted
we saw ministries we saw
first responders counselors cooks
families trying to grieve without it
being on the front page news
we met with the local funeral director
and countless morticians who who hadn't
slept since the mask of the day before
because they've been working 24 7 trying
to handle so many bodies at once
so many little
innocent bodies
who had their entire lives still yet to
live
that is there
that we met two of the grieving parents
ryan
and jessica ramirez
their ten-year-old daughter
alithea
she was one of the 19 children that were
killed
the day before
now aletheia
her dream was to go to art school in
paris and one day share her art with the
world
ryan and jessica were eager to share
alethia's heart with us and said if we
could share it that somehow
maybe that would make
elita smile in heaven
they told us that showing someone else a
lethia's art would in some way
keep her alive
now this particular drawing is a uh
it's a self-portrait
all right of a letha drawing
with her friend in heaven
looking down on her drawing the very
same picture
her mother said of this drawing she said
you know we never really talked to her
about heaven before but somehow she knew
litha
was 10 years old
her father ryan
this man was steady he was uncommonly
together and calm
when a frazzled friend of yours came up
and said how are you so calm
i'd be going crazy
brian told him he said no you wouldn't
no you wouldn't you'd be strong for your
wife and kids because if they see you go
crazy that will not help
just a week prior
ryan got a full-time line job
stringing power lines from pole to pole
and every day since landing that
well-paying full-time job he reminded
his daughter ali there he said girl
daddy gonna spoil you now
told her every single night
he said
daddy's gonna take you to sea world one
day
but he could see he didn't get suppose
his daughter
later
she did not get to go to sleep
so there you have it
part of the video from
matthew mcconaughey talking about the
little girl who was an artist
who was shot down and killed um
and the parents talking about how they
wanted her art to be seen
it's hard to watch
um everyone should watch it
and here's the thing though
is jesse waters on fox news
having watched that because you know
jesse waters watched that thing front oh
yeah front to back watch that thing and
his take on it was his take on this
speech about a person from uvalde
even being famous like matthew
mcconaughey
speaking to the parents of a child who
had their [ __ ] face blown off
by a gun
that jesse waters yeah yeah of freedom
merka
says
makes a joke about tom cruise
talking about inflation as if matthew
mcconaughey doesn't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about when it comes to
yuvaldi it's his hometown you dumb
[ __ ] he lives a truck drive away
from it
they're not listening they're not going
to listen folks
but i'll tell you
i'll tell you
that we need to make them listen we need
to be loud we need to continue this and
really honestly matthew mcconaughey
understands this i i'm not always a
meccano
van okay um
you don't like magic mike
what do you don't like magic mike do you
like magic mike i mean magic mike's
entertaining i'm sure the women in the
chat like it or well whoever you know
i'm not i'm i'm saying i'm saying i his
movies are good i'm not always on
because he he refers to himself
as a aggressive centrist have you ever
heard him say this yeah i mean he says
he said he says it a lot yeah um right
well he he tends to have right wing
tendencies right yeah which you know
isn't surprising and he's from texas
he's got that kind of those those
ideologies ingrained
so
i will say though i am very glad that he
is not running for public office like if
he wants to get involved in politics and
stuff like that you know whatever fine
however
running for governor because that was
something that was you know that was a
possibility all of last year people were
like is he going to run is it not going
to run he's made these kind of
conversations wow
[ __ ] that was all right
i mean it was very much testing the
waters that's the thing is a lot of
right wingers saying that matthew
mcconaughey needs [ __ ] press you're
out of your [ __ ] mind matthew
mcconaughey needs no pr him coming out
and here's him on fox news last night
him coming out against um
republicans on these back door ban
dildos banned porn gun is not the
problem thing yeah because he's coming
out
against them he's not he's not exactly
saying we need to be forgotten he is
literally saying we need to stop this
nonsense because i mean even during his
speech yesterday he said you know we do
need to protect schools so i don't know
to what extent that involves but he is
coming as someone who's like well who
doesn't believe that we need to protect
schools right obvious obviously in this
country no matter what kind of gun
reform we do no matter what kind of um
what kind of safety measures we put in
place background checks waiting periods
there's still more guns than people in
this country right so there's still a
danger to our students now making sure
that our that our schools are prisons
isn't what is going to make our students
safe being being sensical about these
weapons of war is what will help make
not just our students safe but the
grocery stores the community centers the
churches all these places the the
baseball fields
all these places that people are getting
[ __ ] shot at that that will help
using common sense
will help um and he kind of speaks about
it here but he even calls himself an
aggressive centrist which
means he is a republican right he's a
bro he's he he's a republican who
believes
in small liberal ideas when it comes to
social issues yeah yeah let's listen
i've covered washington for a long time
i was a white house correspondent four
administrations ago i talked to some of
my colleagues and they agreed um that
that was the best most authentic most
complete presentation delivered from the
white house podium in many
administrations
i'm not blowing smoke here so i've
covered washington for a long time i was
a white uh well to see that that was
just that that's not the clip i was
looking right but i mean that i mean
that clip right there was like a
backhanded compliment you know right
it's like look
you're okay you're an actor
regardless you went up there and you
gave a very impassioned speech because
it's something that does impact you very
closely now the press room
is a press room you don't have a lot of
people coming in there and making very
passionate pleas
you have people who are the press
secretaries who are coming in and saying
hey here's a brief of what's going on in
the world i'm going to answer questions
again you're not getting very emotional
states happening but you've got uh
you've got fox news saying this is the
most
you know compassion the most emotion
that we've seen come out of that in the
past administrations in that room
forget about forget about the speech
that barack obama gave uh when when
dozens of children were slaughtered at
sandy hook forget about that speech
forget about that passion speech forget
about all the speeches that were given
by anyone but the former game because
when he came out he had no sympathy no
empathy whatever well i mean you know
when he was out there in the rose garden
he's like i don't take any
responsibility at all right yeah it's
not my americans will die it is what it
is it is well apparently 44 of
republicans believe that too um i'm
gonna try to find a clip here of the of
the fox news clip that i thought it was
where where matthew mcconaughey is
talking about how he's a centrist now i
actually believe that uh
bret bear having
uh matthew mcconaughey on is a step
forward but it's not a step forward and
that if you're thinking if you think
that fox news viewers are viewing that
show and going oh
wow well if bret bear has matthew
mcconaughey on instagram i don't here's
the thing i don't think i mean their
numbers might i don't i don't know what
their their view like their viewer
numbers are during the day but i would
imagine that a lot of their viewership
is happening at night we got you know
hannity we've got
carl's saying well yeah they're
listening to the fascist i mean right
exactly i mean those are the people that
can come by or come and watch after work
when they're done dinner all that stuff
during the day you're gonna catch a part
of that market but a part of that market
isn't going to be the people that are
going to get the message that need to
get the message now this is the fox news
clip that i think i was looking for look
at look at the
the banner down below it says gun
responsibility
why is it why is it even close because
is it like a fake thing well because
again matthew mcconaughey actually says
the words gun responsibility that's kind
of his for gun reform or gun control gun
responsibility i mean i say gun safety
like that's what it is
they're putting quotes around it like
yeah okay man yeah yeah okay yeah gun
responsibility it's the boogie man right
gun responsibility okay matthew but
let's let's listen to um him on fox news
here the consensus
word that i'm hearing in phrase is that
this time is different that there is
some more momentum it's different every
time there are some things that they're
willing to not staunchly say no to and
consider that on the left they're
willing to say you know what we may want
the whole loaf but we can't we'll take
slice
of
bread um so
i'm told
that this is a novel thing happening
right now this is a novel and special
time happening right now where actually
something may change instead of just
talking about it and nothing changes
again now here's what i believe i
believe matthew mcdonough gave a great
speech at the white house i believe it
was an impassioned speech i i believe um
him being from evaldi he has the unique
opportunity to speak about it especially
when he spoke to these families and
telling their stories in front of a
microphone but when he goes on fox news
and says this [ __ ] like all both sides
are coming together and all this [ __ ]
and it's not just about talk this time
let me tell you something folks
mitch mcconnell is tricking you he's
[ __ ] with you he's not going to do
anything
john cornyn's not going to do [ __ ] mitch
mcdonald he said that chris murphy came
out the other day and said there are
talks happening but background checks is
something that's like
off the table it's not even on the table
they're only they're only they're only
going to legislate anything but the gun
that's what republicans are going to be
willing to do they're only going to be
willing to do something about yvaldi but
the gun right any anything really you
want to hear that you want to block the
sun you want to block the sun we'll
[ __ ] block the sun for you we will
build a whole program to block the sun
to stop this gun violence right these
shootings but forget that
the nrap the nra pays us way too much
money to make sure that profits remain
in the hands
right you know what we should do is we
should use the guns to shoot the sun oh
that makes sense so everyone everyone
should buy guns to shoot shoot him in
the air right look up at the sun like
trump and go pee pew pew bang bang bang
you're dead and that's a good solution
again
i appreciate matthew mcconaughey going
to the white house and giving his
impassioned speech and i appreciate that
he actually is speaking for some gun
owners out there that are like hey i
would be willing to even give up some of
my guns if it means that we can stop
this nonsense right and give up like i
would do a buy back thing where i would
only own so many or whatever like i
think there's a lot of buy-back programs
work
yeah they do they're probably it wasn't
i think it was in california we had a
buy-back program you know years ago and
it was like hey if you exchange your gun
we'll give you gas cards right
we ran out of [ __ ] gas cards
people were like yeah i got guns dude
you i need gas i need money to pay for
gas we have guns let me just [ __ ]
exchange this they ran out of murdering
they [ __ ] ran out and i would say if
there was ever a time to [ __ ]
incentivize
gas and gun buyback programs
i would do right now in most states did
you know you can actually take your gun
to law enforcement and and they and you
can surrender it like you can say here
they'll take it for you and they will
put it now
depending on the law enforcement i don't
know what to do with it right well
they're suppose technically they're
supposed to
um discard it you know well i'm going to
say that knowing law enforcement i
wouldn't be surprised if a gun goes
missing a serial gets you know
round they couldn't you know but here's
the thing is gun buyback programs aren't
proven to work right
you know this is some of the things but
but matthew mcconaughey going on fox
news and not
i think he's gaslit here i think he's
gaslit i think he actually went to the
white house and i i don't normally speak
against the administration but i think
this administration is fooling
themselves if they think john cornyn or
mitch mcconnell are going to do anything
anything that is even remotely close to
what the american people want that's the
point here is that it doesn't matter if
they [ __ ] fumble around and they pass
a bill that makes back doors lockable
right right get the [ __ ] out of here i
mean we're working with the same people
[ __ ] cornyn is the same guy during
the scotus hearings the nomination
hearings was discussing the hypothetical
of overturning
uh interracial marriage right like these
are the same people that are controlling
our laws that are deciding how we as
americans live and again that's why it's
so important to go and [ __ ] vote
right
it's just it is so important to engage
in our democracy no doesn't matter if
it's for the la mayor or the sheriff
like you did voted for yesterday or your
goddamn congress person or the senator
or your governor or a state legislator
the [ __ ] dog catcher the [ __ ] dog
catcher
we need to make sure has some [ __ ]
sense about them right and and but i do
i do appreciate matthew magana giving
this speech at the white house and using
his platform and his name and his fame
to get this message out but to go on fox
news and to act like and play this game
that republicans because he's doing it
on fox news right
because here's what's going to happen
fox news viewers hear this like oh well
libtard
matthew mcconaughey said on the thing
that the republicans are going to do
this this this and that no they're not
yeah no they're not it's all [ __ ]
that's what mitch mcconnell wants you to
believe that he's going to do something
he's not
let me uh i'm gonna pull up a tweet from
benny johnson you know gotta love that
[ __ ] benny johnson tried to make the
connection about oh the same thing that
the right wing is trying to do right now
they're trying to devalue what matt
mcconaughey said right the impact and
the compassion that he had in that
speech trying to say he was
grandstanding and he came there and he
was some you know some person that was
talking out of their ass and doesn't
really know what they're talking about
now the other thing that people like
benny johnson were pushing was the fact
that matthew mcconaughey
had been in several movies that involved
guns gun violence oh my god he shot a
gun with
and tried to use
tried to use that logic to say
that they should not actually
uh listen to mcconaughey
it says in the goddamn speech that he's
a gun owner right he's talking about
when he was a kid in uvalde how he got a
a [ __ ] pellet gun a daisy bb gun and
then he upgraded to a 410 shotgun you
[ __ ] boneheads don't listen they
don't listen because they don't care to
know what the [ __ ] is happening they
don't care to know and i mean even if
you even if you ignore even if you
ignore the fact that he said he was a
gun owner and he's from texas and he
learned on [ __ ] guns as a kid they're
like oh god how dare you care for these
children that [ __ ] died well i mean
that's true
that's really that's really the thing
they're mad about is matthew mcconaughey
is using facts to make a to make an
argument right i mean the republicans
literally online were like sit down
sit down and shut up well that's because
the reason why is because just yesterday
matthew mcconaughey was her [ __ ] hero
right right and here's here's the tweet
from uh benny johnson this [ __ ] idiot
um matthew mcconaughey more gun control
now also matthew mcconaughey so he takes
scenes from you know what he's finding
he takes made-up stuff right well you
know what's funny about this is these
guns that matthew mcconaughey have and
and we've seen this in the alec baldwin
um where someone was shot on set right
these guns have more regulation and more
control and more safety and more people
who can't touch these [ __ ] guns
unless they have a certain background on
hollywood sets like they you can't even
touch these [ __ ] men i mean i can
tell you from experience so i've been on
set and i've had an ak-47 prop gun
before i played a guard in in a film and
what they did was you've got a prop guy
you got a prop gun person right and
they're the ones they've got a table or
you know wherever they're holding the
guns and they've got it laid out
their
eyes on eyes on the [ __ ]
when you get on the set you get in a
position
and then they call in
the prop gun person wait so you're just
not walking around with the gun just
holding it no sorry tony not walking
around i'm on set i'm on set i get to my
mark they tell me what's going to go on
then they say hey can we get in the prop
gun person the prop gun person comes in
they check
the guns they make sure that nothing's
in there and they they make sure that
everything's good to go haven't they
already checked i mean yes they have
already checked why would you want to
check two three four times what's the
point i don't know it's crazy that you
would want to regulate it and then
they give it to you and then when you're
done with the scene they take it they
check it again
to make sure that in some moment when
they were off screen and and maybe they
missed something they want to make sure
that nothing got jammed nothing got put
in there nothing could all of a sudden
be used as an actual weapon and they
take that they check it they go and they
take it back to their prop area to hold
the guns until the gun needs to be used
again
so it's
it is something like you said it is
totally regulated you have more [ __ ]
checks that happen between when a gun is
on a table to a gun in your hand
right and using a scene
then a gun that is sold to you over the
counter as soon as you turn 18 years old
with a credit card you don't need a
credit card on credit guys 1700 rounds
right you know here's the thing
the guy the the gunman who buys on
credit is like i don't [ __ ] care
because here's the thing i'm not gonna
have to pay it off right and i very much
think that there should be some sort of
clause like if you find that a gun was
bought on credit you know that either
banking institution or that gun shop
there should be some sort of liability
that's attached to them and i know
people oh let's do far well listen if
you're able to buy [ __ ]
guns on imaginary money because that's
what credit is it's imaginary money
until it's paid off on paper
so if you can buy guns for free because
he's not gonna die exactly you know
going back to the guns on set because we
seen the alec baldwin where on a film
that he was on one of the uh one of his
producers i believe was was shot it was
the director the director sorry the
cinematographer yeah cinematographer was
shot who was shot and killed um with one
of the prop guns and
of course all the bad takes from the
republicans were the same though
same bad [ __ ] takes but here's
the thing
if you look at that one situation one
person was killed which uh on film sets
has been the only person there's only
been a few shootings on film sets
because there's so much regulation about
these dangerous [ __ ] weapons because
they're [ __ ] dangerous they can kill
people
she was shot and killed um and of course
the right wing had all these bad dates
about alec baldwin benny johnson was one
of them right don jr was one of them i
mean he made don jr made [ __ ]
t-shirts do you know what's about this
do you know what's funny about that
though
as soon as one person died on set on
accident and it's still being
investigated but it seems like it was
all all roads point to that this was an
accident right because of the
regulations that they have on set
immediately after her death there's a
lot of actors that are saying we
shouldn't even have real guns that are
so dangerous so one person dies one
person dies and the and the union
because it's the union that kind of
controls
these weapons being on set because
there's you know well it's the iatsc
union right correct so they're wanting
to regulate so heavily that they don't
actually have real weapons that the
actors hold right and one person died
right so them saying that matthew
mcconaughey oh look man cunningham wants
to regulate weapons this matthew
mcconaughey the one in in films holding
weapons that are heavily regulated
the entire the entire apparatus of that
film is making sure that that gun is
safe and now because one person died in
one on one film set
on accident now they want to make sure
there's not real guns possibly right you
[ __ ] boneheads don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about there's 19
children and two teachers and you've
already slaughtered by two weapons that
an 18 year old was able to go get for
free at a gun store because he had a
little piece of plastic that said he
could buy something and that gun store
not only gave him two [ __ ]
weapons but 1700 rounds and he went and
murdered and slaughtered 19 children and
two teachers you people need to pluck
your head out of your [ __ ] ass and
realize what's going on and i appreciate
matthew mcconaughey giving that speech
to the white house but what i don't
appreciate is him going on fox news
and and spreading the [ __ ] that
somehow republicans are gonna be in
talks with doing anything about guns
because they might do something about
your schools folks but they're not gonna
do [ __ ] about guns getting there not a
god damn thing it means too much for
their pocketbooks because the nra and
the gun manufacturers are going to spend
almost whatever they can for those
profits for those guns because it's only
a handful of families that are making
this [ __ ] money in this country and
that's the gross [ __ ] thing and i
said it last week i said it last week i
said you know if we regulate the
marijuana industry as hardly as we did
the gun industry in terms of purchasing
you can't go to a dispensary and buy
something on credit because what happens
is the banking institution the financial
institution said we don't accept
drug money
and that's why all these dispensaries
have to deal in cash right or companies
have been made to create their own
credit system uh what have you but
normal banking like chase or wells fargo
or bank of america u.s bank or whatever
they don't accept you to actually buy
marijuana with credit which is made up
money
but they will allow you to buy guns that
kill people one kills people perfect one
makes you [ __ ]
on the couch like you're just lazy on
the couch after 9 11
gabe they didn't burn airplanes
[ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ] um i have a it
looks like a katie porter moment is
going around i'm going to go forward
here
well i'm not sure i'm not sure yet i
don't know i haven't watched this clip
yet but that's a katie porter moment
going around the the twitter verse right
now so i'm going to show this before we
go to a break because we're going to go
to a break and then we're going to gabe
we're going to explain
what these hearings are going to be and
tomorrow how this is going to happen
because i think everyone is wanting to
make sure they watch and listen where
they can and where they can't so i want
to explain that but let's watch this
katie porter moment before we go to
break here
i asked you if that bill was correct if
the bill would allow any gun owner to
maintain possession and you said yes yet
you testified that the bill would allow
people to become felons overnight
earlier today you testified that you
hoped that this was the last time you
testified before congress for the sake
of our nation and the integrity of this
congress
after a mass shooting trying to figure
out how to solve a problem that we are
all heavily invested in solvency
i have nothing to do with your point of
order
how dare you reclaiming my time
how dare you
mistake
the law how dare you legislation you do
not even want an answer to miss swear
i'm moving on
i'm a lifelong consumer
[Laughter]
i don't know what i don't know exactly
what question that's about and what
about this but god damn
katie porter she's like i reclaim my
team now shut up and let me finish my
question she's uh she's giving on so
let's find out what that's about and
when we come back maybe we'll track down
what katie porter is talking about there
and we're also going to go over what the
news is for the hearing tomorrow the
very first january 6 select hearing
which will be in prime time we'll talk
about that right after the bake stick
around if you want to hear about the
earring do not go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live love and blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
[ __ ]
em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the
shows thanks for sticking around through
the break we're gonna track down this kd
porter back and forth to find out what
happened we're also going to explain
[Music]
how these earrings are going to work and
where we're going to broadcast
minus margie holy moly thank you so much
um with the with the super jet wow she's
excited
she's excited she's excited about the uh
the january 6 hearings um we are too uh
so we're going to get to that soon
enough did you track down what this
katie porter is
well yeah i sent you a link and then i
was like oh shoot i gotta send minus
margie a message so oh okay good good
good yeah um thank you thank you thank
you
so so what is this story did you track
it down or is this yeah
it looks like this is an
exchange uh but you create katie porter
is talking about
how quickly
the consumer product safety commission
intervened
after there was a in the tweet kind of
after one child died using a peloton
treadmill last year the consumer product
safety commission intervened when
hundreds of children die using guns
there's no federal response
so it looks like there's a change here
from there's the tweet from recount
right um and and who is who is she
exchanging with i g i'm taking she's
someone from the consumer product safety
commission amy amy swearer
okay so
i couldn't i couldn't
i couldn't distinguish if she was
calling her a swear like you know
oh you know what she works oh boy is she
heritage
foundation person oh my god
i don't know why she's arguing on this
point though but she's a legal fellow at
heritage
and if anyone has no heritage foundation
it's the uh is it not the right wing
uh
nazi uh think tank um that puts out some
bs [ __ ] um they also tried to push the
voter fraud which completely got
debunked um
but yes is this the same exchange here
let's watch yeah same exchange he's
coming in to argue how this
sh we should not actually regulate for
gun violence right right they want to
regulate pelotons after it killed one
person this is the same [ __ ] i was just
talking about
like on movie sets where
benny johnson they're like hey mack is
this matthew mckenna like dude the guns
that he is holding
they were [ __ ] heavily regulated for
him to even touch those [ __ ] guns
right and they're considering not even
having real guns anymore because one
person got killed on a [ __ ] movie set
you people really do need to pluck your
head out of your asses and apparently
miss swearer here needs to pluck her
head out of her ass and katie porter
tells her as much let's listen again
from 2015 to 2020 there were at least
2070 unintentional shootings by children
765
of those children died a consumer
product that causes this much harm to
the public would normally be subject to
a recall but federal law prohibits the
consumer product safety commission the
agency responsible for protecting the
public from dangerous products from
regulating guns
this is absurd after one child died
using a peloton treadmill last year the
consumer product safety commission
intervened and recalled the product but
when hundreds of children die using guns
there is no federal response there is no
federal safety standard for guns
so there you go that's what they're
upset that's what katie porter's upset
about and she's right she's correct
these are consumer products if if
everyone can get them and anyone can get
them
then why shouldn't we [ __ ] regulate
them jesus christ they always want to
compare cars and airplanes do you know
how many [ __ ] figure federal
regulations there are for a god damn
airplane still scalise you dumb son of a
[ __ ] i mean i mean
these
this is the same thing by the way i
don't know if i only know about this
because it made headlines was if anyone
watches sex in the city they had their
reboot or uh kind of
next
edition that they came up with lately
but there was a death or heart attack
that happened on the show
from a peloton and peloton was like oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa no no no no we got
to make clear that peloton is not
actually connected with any sort of uh
health related incidents that you might
die from right and the fact that it was
faked it was faked yeah it was it was it
was not real it was fake it was on set
you know all this stuff and you've got
these same people who are trying to push
the idea that we should overly regulate
or we we should cover
these products that that
people have in their homes every day but
we shouldn't handle the guns that are in
the homes of these people every day
where you are 25 times more likely
i think it's to die
or or at least get shot by the gun
that's in your own home that you own
gabe gabe think about this for a second
it makes sense i mean just a little bit
of sense that if you're never really in
a close proximity or presence of a gun
you're probably less likely to receive i
don't know any kind of gunshot wound it
doesn't it really it doesn't make any
sense it's almost understand that
it's almost like
if you were to split two groups right
people who are
uh more likely to
um take covet seriously and take
protocols get their vaccine their
booster shot where their mask
you would see those people come together
and you would say
oh weird
the transmission rate is much lower
but the people who have no mass didn't
get boosted give me a vaccine and are
partying the clubs and brunch and all
this stuff and just we had a
transmission so i guess i guess you
could say
i guess you could say the more guns that
there are the more likely the
transmission rate of a bullet
around going through you and someone
pointed out the face here of these two
and this says it all really this this
screenshot um she's a legal fellow i
don't give her much credit yeah [ __ ]
heritage foundation [ __ ] her law degree
she can take it and stick it up her
[ __ ] fascist ass
katie porter is correct and the american
people should be demanding that that
that the consumer protection agency
protect children which is their [ __ ]
mission it doesn't matter what the
product is it doesn't matter what it is
right they should be able to protect
children and that's the way it should be
so go get [ __ ] miss swearer
jesus christ
okay i do want to get into
the announcements for the january 6th
select hearing there's like going to be
six of them but tomorrow is the very
first one so i want to talk about that
one specifically
tomorrow the hearing gabe it starts at 8
00 pm eastern it's a prime time hearing
it's going to be what we understand a
90-minute presentation at this point um
we even have heard that jared and ivanka
some of their recorded testimony might
even be part of that presentation we're
not sure exactly what the presentation
is going to be i mean other than
revealing that they wanted to overturn
our government um because that's what
happened we just need to see the
evidence right we need to see the facts
now that bears out we know what happened
and we can tell what they were trying to
do
so here's the thing
the the actual gavel is going to come
down at 8 00 pm eastern time so that's 9
central okay that is 7 pacific p.m in
the evening now what we are going to do
is we are going to host the midas touch
coverage
of these hearings we're going to start
an hour early and we're going to have
commentary we're going to have
commentary from people like politics
girl lee mcgowan um the folks from legal
af are going to be there and several
other folks that i know you people are
going to know yeah you're going we have
some very exciting guest planned for the
first day and we've also got some other
people
playing throughout june for the other
hearings so very exciting stuff but
tomorrow we will start that coverage at
7 00 p.m eastern so go to the midas
touch channel right now gabe can you put
that link
in in the chat for everyone so they can
go to that youtube link and they can set
their reminder because we will start an
hour before the hearing to talk about
the hearing itself we're also any breaks
that may happen so if the committee
takes a break which they normally do we
will do commentary during that break so
you can watch commentary during that
break and then we will also follow up
the hearing with commentary afterwards
from our special guest that will be
joining us on this special coverage but
again we are going to be producing the
special coverage for the midas touch on
the midas touch youtube channel so make
sure to go follow this link set your
reminder now don't forget to set the
reminder and follow midas touch also
follow us
on youtube while you're at youtube you
might as well follow the tony michaels
what's up send us a dm stay right say
hello that's right that's right go
comment on on on your favorite video
over there um even the drive-thru videos
you can go comment on those too
uh
you can also follow us on twitter that's
where you'll find some of these updates
about the hearings now you'll find out
about some of the guests go to
tonymichaelspod on twitter also follow
me and gabe at the tony michaels and i
am gabe sanchez over on twitter to make
sure and to to follow all the links to
these hearings we will be tweeting about
them we will be posting them but make
sure you set your reminder for this
first hearing gabe you got that link in
the uh
i just said uh
tomorrow june 9th at 7 00 pm
eastern and then the link is below i
will i can send it again okay so but
yeah we will be streaming that's right
twitter or sorry on on youtube and on on
facebook right yes we'll also be uh
simulcasting to the facebook page of
midas touch but you really uh because
facebook you have the ability to chat
but if you want to chat with a lot of
people in the youtube chat in the live
chat there will be live chat going on
over on the youtube channel as well so
make sure make sure that you go set your
reminder for that youtube link you can
watch it on facebook too but we will
have the live chat open on youtube um to
go do that so and again follow us over
on youtube while you're there that would
help us out as well
now
i also want to tell you what's going to
happen
with the download so we are going to
download parts of these hearings to our
directory then the tony michaels podcast
on apple spotify google so make sure you
go to your directory that you use
whether it be apple spotify google
whatever directory you're you're using
to download your podcast and go go
subscribe there because you will be able
to download the audio version
of the hearing and our coverage of the
hearing
on those directories so make sure
make sure to also subscribe at your
favorite
your favorite directory gabe i'm super
excited about this coverage we've worked
pretty hard this week of getting
graphics together well i mean we're
doing a lot of things this is this has
been uh
uh this has been
i mean we were talking about this last
month yes as soon as they were i mean i
remember as soon as they started talking
about it we're like talking about them
we need to we need to stream this i mean
because you know we had previously done
the marjorie taylor green
uh election hearing that they had in
georgia and uh and we we were saying
that we should do another one yeah
because we had we had karen uh nippolo
from legal af kfa right legal af came
and joined us for the marjorie taylor
green earring and we streamed for uh
jeez it was like eight hours yeah i went
eight hours without taking a piss yeah i
took a small break to go get something
to eat and i came back and and mind you
tony was like i'm going to take a break
i'm going to take a break and then i
came back and he was still on so i never
done it for the rest i never took a
break never take a while i i i snuck out
and did some magic tricks to go to the
bathroom once or twice but but other
than that i set for the entire eight
hours i would imagine that this hearing
with 90 minutes an hour before an hour
after if they do a couple breaks um
we'll probably be streaming for about
three or four hours yeah um tomorrow
evening so we're gonna do our show
tomorrow don't miss our show we do the
show every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central for two
hours so tomorrow we will do the show
just like we always do in the morning
and then we will do the the coverage for
the hearing in the evening on the minus
touch and
i want to say i want to thank the
mizellas brothers because we've been
talking to them for quite some time
about uh streaming this uh they had they
wanted some ideas about how to stream
the hearing live um and they've
entrusted us to produce um this live
stream so i want to thank the my zealous
brothers over minus touch for giving us
the opportunity um to to entrusting us
with this such important production um
and i hope i hope we don't let the
audience down i hope we don't let the my
zealous brothers down and i know i know
our guest will be 100
percent supreme it's going to be
fantastic to have the commentary from
the guests that we will have um we're
actually going to do some sound tests um
this afternoon so we'll be confirming
some of these guests and maybe we'll put
out announcements i think there's
already been some announcements uh right
out there on the twitterverse that you
can go see on midas touch yeah facebook
i was gonna i was gonna point out it
sounds like people are already trying to
make a game of these hearings oh are
they okay yeah so it sounds like there's
going to be drinking yeah that's yeah so
so go to you guys if you wanna if you
wanna make sure to participate in
democracy but make it fun and
lighthearted and see if you can get
wasted by the end of the night don't
forget to go to the youtube chat so go
go
find that link and subscribe and set the
reminder for that link because i'm
telling you if you want to participate
in those drinking games it sounds like
they're going to play those
in the live chat there so
um go do that but i wanna again i wanna
thank uh and and gabe i wanna i wanna
thank you because you have worked really
hard on all these graphics i know we've
changed some different things several
times we're trying to get it correct so
it all looks the same it's going to have
the same feel that our show has yeah but
there are some differences because it's
special coverage um but everyone joined
i think i think
once we get thursday up and running and
kind of get that under our belt then the
rest will kind of be yeah it'll fall
into place it'll be pretty easy
so so it will look similar to what we do
here on the tony michaels podcast
because we are producing it to look very
similar um to that production but gabe
thank you for for all your hard work and
everyone thank gabe out there because
you know i i couldn't make this show
look as good the graphics the thumbnails
wouldn't be as good um it just wouldn't
happen without the the artistic graphic
design ability the magic wand that gabe
sanchez has over there i call it the
magic wand yeah you know because i do
make some of the graphics you know some
of them not a lot some of them but every
once in a while i i gotta call on gabe
like hey i need your your magic wand
there's something that sometimes he'll
just watch me as i yeah yeah i'm
watching the magic happen yeah right
yeah it's like it's like graphic art
porn kind of thing but yeah no lumen and
tubing yeah no aluminum tubing no
none of that none of that none of that
this is not it's safe for work it's safe
for work kind of stuff so yeah but
everyone please join us tomorrow evening
for the coverage it is super important
not just to watch the commentary but
it's too important for you your
neighbors your friends your family your
colleagues and
even even some of your young children to
understand what happened on that day of
january 6 and i think tomorrow with this
90-minute presentation they really are
going to lay it out the good news is is
that it will be available to to be
replayed i'm sure in several places i
know on
our channels and
it will be able to be replayed um but i
want to also stress that it's so
important that those moments that you
find
that really can explain in a quick 15 20
30 seconds of what these people were
trying to do to our country and trying
to do to our democracy it is super
important that we work very hard to get
that in from the eyeballs it's as many
people as we possibly can it is so
important that americans understand what
happened that day to our democracy and
what they wanted to do to it and what
they're continuing
to try to do to it so don't forget to
join us tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central just like you do every single
weekday monday through friday on youtube
twitter twitch and simulcasting from the
minus touch facebook page and then
tomorrow evening
seven o'clock p.m eastern time we will
start the special coverage of the
january 6th select committee public
hearings yep until tomorrow morning
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking